ja wieder mal erschüttert einen
pädophilen ring deutschland die täter
missbrauchten kleine kinder auf
brutalste art und vorstellbar das
jüngste opfer soll gerade einmal einen
monat alt gewesen sein und auf die spur
dieses kinderschänder rings kam die
polizei durch einen verfahren in berlin
70 tatverdächtige in 14 bundesländern
das ist der kinderschänderring den die
ermittler sprengen in seinem zentrum ein
44 jähriger aus wermelskirchen in nrw
seit november letzten jahres ermittelt
die sonderkommission bab liste es geht
um millionen fotos und videos und einen
zeitraum von vier jahren in dem die
kinderschänder agierten unter den opfern
zahlreiche babys das jüngste gerade
einmal einen monat alt und ich bin
wirklich erschüttert und fassungslos
ein solches ausmaß an
menschenverachtender brutalität
und gefühlloser gleichgültigkeit
gegenüber dem leid von kleinen kindern
schmerzen und ihren schreien und ihrer
offensichtlichen angst ist mir noch
nicht begegnet man so etwas habe ich mir
auch nicht vorstellen können der
hauptverdächtige sitzt in
untersuchungshaft
er soll die kinder missbraucht und
gefilmt haben das material über chats
mit anderen pädophilen im internet
verbreitet haben die staatsanwaltschaft
köln bereitet die anklage vor und prüft
eine sicherheitsverwahrung
und im studio ist jetzt rainer becker er
ist vorsitzender der deutschen
kinderhilfe herr becker also wir hören
jetzt tatsächlich wieder mal war dieser
kinderschänderring war die menschen die
daran beteiligt waren über jahre
offensichtliche im darknet im internet
aktiv wurden nicht dabei gestört wie
kann das sein dass diese pädophilen
immer wieder so lange unentdeckt ihr
unwesen treiben können die ermittler
haben natürlich immer ganz erhebliche
probleme die sich an recht und gesetz
gebunden werden natürlich die täter sich
nicht an recht und gesetz halten und wir
hatten bislang bis zum juli vergangenen
jahres eine regelung dass sexueller
missbrauch von kindern bislang noch kein
verbrechen war wenn man wirklich
unglaublich was man an dieser stelle
wirklich noch mal betonen ist war langer
kampf vor lambrecht zu überzeugen aber
bild hatte da sehr gut mit geholt
und jetzt wo es zum verbrechen geworden
ist bestehen auch erleichterte
möglichkeiten zb verdeckte ermittler
einzusetzen oder mehr technik
einzusetzen aber es ist natürlich
schwierig ist bedarf hinweisen und die
ermittler können nicht einfach präventiv
schauen was da sache ist auch wenn im
moment natürlich intensiv darüber
diskutiert wird eine chat kontrolle
durchzuführen im moment gibt es menschen
die der meinung sind der datenschutz ist
ihnen wichtiger und damit auch den
schutz solcher menschen als die
gesundheit und das leben oder auch dann
ist das ja ganz anders genau und das ist
ja auch unglaublich main wer will denn
hier noch was von datenschutz wissen ja
also man muss doch einfach gucken dass
man die täter dann auch wirklich zu
fassen kriegt ich teile ihre auffassung
wenn sie wurde so chad kontrollen
vergleichen wollen müssen sie sich das
mit der radarkontrolle vorstellen jeder
hat ein auto kennzeichen fährt durch die
stadt und jedes auto wird wenn irgendwo
ein blitz soll steht erfasst darüber
regt sich auch keiner auf denn es
passiert ja auch nichts wenn er nichts
macht und das weiß jeder und alle nehmen
das als normal hin und jetzt tut man so
als sei dass der skandal wenn man eine
chat kontrolle will das ist nicht die
lösung täter finden immer irgendwo
andere wege ob das dann über
verlinkungen glaubt über spiele die sind
sehr erfinderisch aber man muss brauchen
wir ihnen deutlich machen wir sind euch
auf den fersen wo immer ihr seid wenn
ihr nicht aufhört was für material
kursiert da überhaupt im netz und woher
kommen die pädophilen dass das sind
fotos die entweder in deutschland
gemacht worden sind von menschen die mit
ihren kindern leben das sind aber auch
menschen die sich von anderen kinder zu
führen lassen das sind auch aufnahmen
aus dem ausland weil es eben geld bringt
und ich sage jetzt mal so es geht ja
nicht nur um kinderpornografie es geht
um das was man den kindern antut
dahinter ob nun in deutschland oder
irgendwo auf der welt und das muss
nachhaltig verfolgt werden also
nordrhein westfalen macht es uns vor und
wir haben auch wieder ein problem das
ist die masse es kann nur jemand
angeklagt werden der
sachen die man ihm definitiv nachweisen
kann und wenn sie dann irgendwo 100.000
dateien haben dann kann man den nur
wegen 100.000 dateien verurteilen wenn
man die auch gesehen und ausgewertet hat
das geht nicht ohne künstliche
intelligenz und wenn man dann irgendwo
sagte stoppen bei 1000 dann werden
99.000
wegrutschen oder das urteil wird muss
entsprechend milde ausfallen so was kann
und darf nicht sein jetzt ist es nun den
ermittlern gelungen mal einen regen mal
wieder zu sprengen mal wieder ein paar
täter aufzuspüren zum glück aber
offensichtlich ergeben ja sehr sehr
viele menschen unentdeckt weiterhin im
internet hat man irgendwie noch eine
gewisse vorstellung davon wie viele
pädophile es überhaupt gibt in
deutschland
man sagt das ist so drei bis fünf
prozent pädosexuelle gibt wir nehmen den
begriff pädophile nicht weil es sehr
heiß menschen die kinder lieben wir denn
das einfach pädosexuelle das ist eine
veranlagung wie auch homosexualität und
eigentlich in anführungsstrichen kann
keiner was dafür nur wenn das umsetzt
und auslebt dann beginnt natürlich die
strafbarkeit und es gibt auch
pädosexuelle die kämpfen wie die löwen
das ist nicht ausleben die beiden
kontakt zu kindern die nehmen
medikamente
und versuchen ein ganz normales leben zu
führen und da gibt es eben leute die das
auszuleben versuchen berufe ergreifen wo
sie mit kindern arbeiten wo sie kontakt
haben zu kindern wo sie glauben
besonders geschützt zu sein vor
verfolgung das ist ein wahnsinnig
breites feld und zu behaupten das sei
dann so ein ersatz dass menschen die
kinderpornografisches material sich
anschauen oder missbraucht bilder dass
die dann nicht übergriffig werden das
passt so auch nicht es gibt
untersuchungen die besagen wenn bei
einer durchsuchung
kinderpornografisches material
sichergestellt wird muss man im grunde
davon ausgehen dass mindestens 20
prozent der konsumenten auch selber
aktiv kinder missbrauchen kann verletzt
hainich ja herr becker danke dass sie
bei uns waren danke für diese
erläuterung wir hoffen dass auf diesem
gebiet noch eine ganze menge passiert
zum schutz der kinder dankeschön